steve weintraub collider
that's who i was waiting for i was like
where's steve
i'm sure he's on the way
i uh sure i'll pretend that's true and
i'll say thank you no for sure
because also don't usually wear nail
varnish i do actually
not not today but yes i i take back what
i just said
how are you doing i'm okay how are you
i can't complain i'm glad i get to talk
to you in the blue void in the blue void
of
zoom right let's start with the most
important question right up front
how much did you pay to be in the great
british bake off
do you know what's amazing one you're
the first person to ask thank you
it the best thing about being on the
bake off once one of my favorite shows
obviously love for it
love it but for every contestant that
goes on they donate money to charity
it's uh amazing i had
the best time didn't do a great job
but didn't cry so you know was it a five
pound note or a twenty pound note that
you slipped the producers
you know honestly i think i mentioned it
so much like i
really try and manifest things into
existence so like i kept talking about
needing a job and like finally i have
some jobs
and then i was talking about great
british breakout got to do that kept
talking about rupaul got to do that
it's great listen i know that it must
have been awesome working with tom it
was like
family i all the all the cliched
comments i've heard
i really want to know what it was like
working with the dogs that played manche
the dog singular oh it was just one dog
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean manche did
all his own
stunts except for the times that we were
throwing a toy around that looked like
manchu which was honestly so creepy
uh the thing about well-trained dogs is
they're sort of um scary it's like
like all of the things you associate
with a dog like having a pair
like having a like oh you know dookie
not so much with manche
so he was great he was really well
behaved but then when we were filming in
haven there was a sheepdog who was
great so we actually got a nice variety
of dogs to work with
uh you've done obviously a lot of stunts
uh through your career already
uh i did hear that the stuff in the
river that you had to do was like
the water was extremely cold um i heard
it was a challenge
am i wrong about this well the thing is
nothing beats filming an outdoor uh
scene with waves crashing on you in
november uh
with adam driver swinging a stick at you
so in comparison to that
it was really fun and also it was a
really hot summer
but being in churning water with david
yellow who's the nicest man in the world
being
absolutely terrifying as the preacher
that was genuinely scary yeah
i guess you worked with simon crane who
did second unit on this
yes um and i'm curious you've worked
with obviously a number of different
second unit directors
is there is there anything that is
similar about a lot of those guys or
girls or is it sort of
you know what is simon like for example
simon is an angel on earth
he literally fell asleep when he was
in a plane and fell out of a plane he
used to double james bond he is the
clumsiest man ever he's
so wonderful but he's like known for
being clumsy he literally fell
out of a plane for real like a legit i
think he was going parachuting or
something
and it was hilarious because the couple
scenes he did he was like tripping over
tree roots and everything i was like how
were you a stunt man
but he's amazing he's so smart he's so
i'm really excited for him to be
directing directing a film
because he's just wonderful really
wonderful
uh so actually being serious for one
second about uh what was it about the
material
i heard you were a fan of the books what
was it about the
the books and the material that said i
really want to do this
i well i read the script and thought it
was great and obviously the script has
gone through a lot of changes since
since then and then read the books which
are obviously great
um i just thought it was a very
interesting concept it's obviously
amazing because it's although it's based
on a book it's an original
concept in a big budget way which is
nice
um but i just thought i love what
patrick ness does
and i thought you know the overarching
thing of it being this action adventure
but actually with all of these
you know intense themes underneath it uh
it's
that's what i think is beautiful about
film that it can be this one thing and
it can be
loads of other things and the response
it's provoking in people it's so
interesting how people are taking it
um so it's just great to be part of
something that is like a conversation
like people really have a reaction to it
because i'm almost out of time i'm gonna
do a three-part last question
you like this uh i'm really excited
about young women in the city
uh also women in the castle and you
might be working with neil berger on the
marsh king's daughter
uh can you yeah can you talk about all
three of those projects from what
excites you about all three
uh women in the castle is a
very sad story but it's basically
a sort of side of post-second world war
that we haven't seen so much which is
the reality that um
a lot of german people were uh sad
that hitler was gone because you know a
lot of people's lives were
fine like were fine under him so it's an
interesting ex
explanation of that and chris and scott
thomas who is unbelievable and nina
who is unbelievable and jane our
incredible writer director so that's
just really exciting
uh young women in the sea amazing
she was such a trailblazer and a story
that i didn't know
things like basically they tried to get
her to fail because
if she won it would be like this new
time in women's sport and it would
the the men's sport didn't want that so
what she did was
amazing and then the marsh king's
daughter which is actually the first
thing i'm doing with neil
is just a really exciting beautiful
script about human nature
and yearning and upbringing and i
can't wait super excited on that note i
gotta go uh great talking with you
as always good luck with your speed
dating thank you
thank you